bien merci de votre présence nous venons
de terminer une heure et demie de
travail du comité de campagne avec les
membres du comité de campagne
nous sommes en ordre de bataille pour
préparer cette campagne des législatives
nous n'avons pas perdu tant depuis le
soir du premier tour des élections
législatives
je veux d'abord remercier nos amis et
partenaires de l'ue dei qui ont à nos
côtés depuis quinze jours mise en place
la confirmation de la préparation de
l'accompagnement de la sélection nos
candidats qui s'inscriront dans la
logique d'accompagnement du
renouvellement des visages des hommes ou
des femmes ancrés dans leur territoire
et qui porteront les couleurs majorité
pour la france union de la droite et du
centre qui sera à la fois l'étiquette
est le slogan de nos candidats puisque
le projet politique dans les quatre
semaines qui viennent c'est
effectivement de donner une majorité
pour la france sur la base de nos
valeurs de nos engagements de nos
convictions et sur la base du projet
c'est le deuxième point puisque dans le
même esprit d'unité d'union et en même
temps de se projeter vers l'avant au
lendemain de l'élection du président
macron auquel nous avons adressé nos
félicitations républicaines et auquel
nous souhaitons naturellement bonne
chance dans la mission élevé qui est la
sienne
mais pour cela nous nous sommes mis en
situation de frire un projet qui réponde
aux aspirations exprimées par les
français au soir du premier tour notre
analyse politique n'est pas la lecture
du soir des résultats du second tour
mais bien la réalité d'un pays fracturé
comme jamais avec quatre blocs à 20% et
qui justifie pleinement que nous ayons
corrigé amendé améliorée et enrichie en
quelque sorte être en phase avec les
attentes des français
ce projet il ne sera donc pas le projet
porté par notre candidat françois fillon
auquel nous rendre hommage également
pour son courage la ténacité et la
manière dont il a créé les conditions
d'une attention autour d'une volonté
d'une alternance sans équivoque et puis
l'un changement en profondeur de notre
société notamment sur le plan économique
sur le plan social sur le plan de la
restauration de l'autorité de l'état sur
le plan du réarmement de l'étang sur le
plan de la cohésion sociale sur le plan
de l'équilibré des territoires et la
mission a été confiée à eric woerth avec
les représentants
lui dit pendant plusieurs jours pour à
la fois aboutir à la synthèse qui on
doit la vérité de reconnaître n'a pas
été faite au lendemain de la primaire
des position équilibrée avec un message
est le plus important puisque la
priorité est à la fois sur l'autorité de
l'état et l'autre priorité et sur
l'économie et le social donc la synthèse
portera eric woerth le présentera devant
vous dans quelques instants
autour d'une augmentation du pouvoir
d'achat des français notamment les
classes moyennes qui ont été massacrés
au cours de ce quinquennat de françois
hollande pour laquelle immanuel macron
dans les responsabilités qui étaient les
siennes a naturellement sa part de
responsabilité et d'une baisse des
impôts
nous rentrerons dans le détail dans
quelques instants autour de cela le même
esprit de synthèse nous a animés pour
proposer justement de garder la vélocité
l'énergie du projet de notre candidat et
en même temps d'avoir un projet de
rassemblement et qui rend entendu
clairement le message des français sur
la méthode de campagne
christian jacob que je salue qui anime
le comité de campagne autour de bernard
accoyer présentera immédiatement la mise
en mouvements énergiques et et vigoureux
pour les quatre semaines car c'est une
campagne qui va être très courte elle
est extraordinairement rapide donc dès
demain nous serons sur le terrain après
avoir présenté le projet nous le
déclineront il y aura tout un rythme de
grands meetings régionaux et puis le
déploiement de nos orateurs nationaux
qui se comptent parmi le visage du
bureau politique de notre formation
ainsi que les représentants donnée par
l'ue dei
et puis il y aura une structuration de
l'organisation de campagnes notamment
pour la presse et les médias et pour les
généralistes que vous êtes avec toutes
les fenêtres disponibles l'intervention
de débats d'expression et puis en
fonction du rythme qui sera proposé
aussi par la nouvelle organisation
gouvernementale et les textes qui seront
proposés avec une série de portes
paroles que je salue et qui vous seront
présentés par christian jacob je cède la
parole à présent à bernard accoyer à
l'issue nous serons à votre disposition
pour répondre à vos questions
les républicains prépare depuis
longtemps les élections législatives et
nous le faisons dans l'unité avec nos
amis de lydie ici présent nous avons
engagé ce travail et il y a maintenant
près de six mois pour préparer les
investitures l'equilibre de cette unité
kate unités particulièrement solide et
partout dans les 577 circonscriptions
nos candidats d'union sont déjà à pied
d'oeuvre
mais nous jugeons cette élection est
essentielle parce qu'elle va être le
seul moment d'une véritable consultation
démocratique pour nos compatriotes
en effet la présidentielle s'est
déroulée chacun le sait dans des
conditions extravagantes et les français
ont été privés d'un débat démocratique
essentiel pour la vie démocratique de
notre pays
aujourd'hui dans nos institutions qui
sont celles d'un régime parlementaire
[Musique]
le débat politique des élections
législatives revêt toute son importance
car c'est bien de la majorité que les
ans que les français auront choisi
d'envoyer à l'assemblée nationale que
relèvera la politique qui sera conduite
dans les années à venir avec le
président de la république que les
français viennent d'élire et c'est pour
cette raison que ces élections sont un
temps de respiration démocratique
indispensable dans quelques instants
vous donnera le détail du déroulement de
cette campagne
pour ce qui est des républicains
famille politique ici au centre national
dans les fédérations partout en france
est mobilisée et le socle que constitue
l'union elle est rude et y alla proches
de ces législatives reste et je le dis
en responsabilité l'un des derniers
points constant et solide de la vie
politique française nous mesurons
l'importance de nos responsabilités nous
abordons cette campagne dans un esprit
d'ouverture sans sectarisme prêt à
travailler avec tout le monde mais nous
considérons qu'il y a d'abord le temps
du choix démocratique des français qui
va s'exprimer maintenant
lors de cette campagne puis du vote des
élections législatives
je remercie
bien merci
l'élection présidentielle vient d'avoir
lieu nous avons un nouveau président de
la république et le quinquennat ce qui
s'ouvre doit être une réussite si
c'était un échec
le quinquennat en l'occurrence ce serait
les français qui en paiera les pots
cassés
et cette réussite c'est l'objet du
travail que nous avons fait au cours des
quinze derniers jours depuis notre
défaite au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle elle doit dépendre de
notre point de vue du projet que nous
pouvons apporter à la france et aux
français ce projet île à françois baroin
et bernard acoyer l'a dit lundi il a été
retravaillé
il a été retravaillé pour prendre en
compte ce qu'ont dit les français lors
de l'élection présidentielle et pour
permettre je crois de lui donner à la
fois plus d'ambition et plus d'équité
plus d'ambition en tout cas que celui
qui est porté par notre président de la
république parce qu'il y a besoin de
réformes qui ne soit pas floues mais qui
permettent de rouvrir le marché du
travail en france de reconstruire un
ascenseur éducatif de faire en sorte que
l'europe se rebaptise en se fondant sur
l'essentiel et pas sur l'accessoire
qu'elle s'occupe des granges enjeux
stratégiques et pas de norme tout à fait
secondaire est de faire en sorte qu'on
rétablisse et je reconnais que dans
cette campagne s'est passé
malheureusement trop inaperçu qu'on
rétablisse l'autorité de l'état qui est
la garantie pour les français à la fois
de leur sécurité et de la justice mais
également un projet qui est plus
équitable ou la défense du pouvoir
d'achat la protection des plus faibles
la capacité des salariés notamment des
salariés les plus modestes à retrouver
des marges de manoeuvre à travers on le
verra tout à l'heure la défiscalisation
des heures supplémentaires par exemple
la baisse de l'impôt sur le revenu bref
une capacité à dire aux français bien
sûr que notre pays pour retrouver ses
ambitions doit faire un certain nombre
d'efforts et de transformation
mais ces efforts doivent être
équitablement répartis et c'est
l'engagement que dans la plateforme
les républicains nous fêtons prendre et
puis sur les débats qui sont en cours
moi je veux faire deux observations
la première des choses c'est que
j'entends parler de recomposition
politique et la recomposition politique
ce n'est jamais une démarche
individuelle c'est une démarche
collective et il n'y a pas de démarche
collective dans ce convoi
on a beaucoup de discours sur la
recomposition mais uniquement des
tentatives de captage individuel je le
dis comme je le pense
or refonder la vie politique française
ça ne peut pas passer par de vieilles
pratiques qui sont en réalité la
proposition de placer deux postes
oubliant nos idées si nous avons perdu
l'élection présidentielle nous n'avons
perdu ni nos idées nos valeurs ni nos
projets c'est ce que nous devons
présenter ensemble aux français je le
dis d'autant plus que je suis frappée
depuis hier par un discours qui paraît
de la part du mouvement du président de
la république très ouvert mais qui en
réalité se traduit par une fermeture
assez grande je veux le souligner
laventure ou la mésaventure de manuel
valls hier montre une réaction brutale à
quelqu'un qui manifestement avait envie
de travailler avec le nouveau président
de la république je pense que ça doit
servir de leçon
abandonner ses idées abandonné sa
formation
c'est en réalité le mée revivre le
meilleur moyen de se faire claquer la
porte au nez et d'éviter la
recomposition politique dont tout le
monde parle cette recomposition elle
aura ou pas lieu en fonction du vote des
français soit ils choisissent de donner
à lui dit et républicains une majorité
et nous aurons un travail constructif à
faire en direction des français aux
côtés du nouveau président de la
république soit ils choisissent de lui
signer un chèque en blanc
et ça n'a jamais fonctionné soit ils
choisissent que la majorité relative se
dessine et à ce moment là il faudra que
lui dit les républicains et l'ensemble
des forces politiques en tire les
conséquences
mais je trouve assez comment dirais-je
invraisemblable de vouloir zapper le
débat législatif
je terminerai par là le débat
présidentiel et on le regardait tout à
l'heure dans une analyse de l'eau
nyon n'a pas eu lieu sur le fond et sur
les valeurs il ya une frustration
aujourd'hui c'est nos concitoyens de
savoir comment on traite les sujets de
chômage de la sécurité de l'éducation de
la protection sociale de la couverture
médicale et c'est le débat que nous
devons ouvrir avec enthousiasme au cours
de cette élection de façon répétée
respectueuse de toutes les forces
politiques et comme le disait bernard
acoyer au moment où tout le monde est
instable
nous nous voulons cette stabilité une
stabilité qui permet aux français de
parler de ce que nous allons changer
pour eux demain et non pas seulement de
parler comme beaucoup de même de ce
qu'ils veulent occuper comme
responsabilités ça c'est un sujet qui
est totalement déplacée aujourd'hui nous
commençons à construire
nous le souhaitons une majorité pour la
france cette majorité elle se fait dans
l'unité elle se fait dans un projet
rénover plus ambitieux et plus équitable
est sévère les français maintenant de
nous allons nous tourner pour qu'ils
décident s'ils nous confie la majorité
on sait qui va présider la france la
question de la législative c'est de
savoir qui va gouverner
bien donc rapidement on a mis en place
ce matin notre comité de campagne avec
une une équipe qui est à la fois
concentré autour no2 de chefs de nos
deux familles politiques donc la
direction exécutive des républicains au
tour de bernard accoyer
la direction de l'ugtt et y autour de
jean-christophe lagarde
on y associe également les les
présidents des grandes associations
d'élus c'est à dire les maires de france
les départements les régions
l'ancien comité de campagne donc avec
nos anciens candidats à la primaire ou
leurs représentants les présidents des
groupes parlementaires
les vice présidents de deux de
l'assemblée bon ce qui doit faire une
équipe
entre 30 et 40 personnes qui permet à la
fois d'avoir une représentation là la
plus large des différentes sensibilités
qui puisse y avoir mais surtout des gens
qui ont à la fois une expérience et puis
une implantation locale qui permet de
bien travailler pour préparer cette
campagne également une équipe de
porte-parole avec florence portelli
damien abad david lisnard
philippe vigier catherine vautrin franck
proust philippe cochet donc ils doivent
être six ou sept je crois la ligne est
simple pour nous à vient d'être évoquée
par par françois parot bernard et par
jean-christophe nous sommes en situation
de pouvoir gagner ces législatives et
nous y allons clairement pour gagner
avec un atout qui est celui de l'ancrage
territorial de nos de nos candidats au
moment où en marché en difficulté on
voit bien pour pour ses investitures et
puis parallèlement à cela au moment
aussi on assiste à une explosion au
moins deux grandes difficultés au sein
de l'appareil l'appareil front national
nous nous avons un projet
ce qui nous rassemble qui a tenu compte
du des résultats du premier tour eric va
vous le vous le présenter dans un
instant donc cette campagne se fait à la
fois sur des terrains sur des candidats
qui ont une implantation de terrain donc
campagne de proximité avec un large
déploiement de tous nos orateurs nous
orateurs nationaux parallèlement à cela
on va là rythmé avec des grands meetings
régionaux le lancement on va vraiment
être le 20 mars le vin le 20 mai au parc
au parc floral et nous allons faire dans
chacune des régions des grands meetings
régionaux mais ensuite se démultiplier
effectivement sur l'ensemble des
circonscriptions
l'autre point important c'est qu'une
campagne elle doit être incarnée et nous
avons un chef de file qui l'incarnent
c'est à dire que les français ont bien
reçu ce message c'est que nous voulons
être en situation d'avoir la majorité
demain et donc de l'exercer de pouvoir
gouverner avec un premier ministre qui
serait françois baroin si nous avons
effectivement la majorité et je pense
que entre la proximité la campagne de
terrain de nos candidats
la manière dont françois baroin incarne
notre notre projet au niveau national et
bien les quand les conditions sont sont
réunis pour
pour faire le meilleur résultat possible
les meilleurs résultats possibles c'est
d'être majoritaire le 18 juin bien
écouter on vous a distribué le document
je vais parcourir rapidement si vous le
voulez bien
c'est une travail qui a été réalisé en
peu de temps mais la droite avait
travaillé pendant la droite et le centre
travaillé pendant deux ans quasiment
d'arrache-pied sur les sur les projets
donc l'idée était de regarder comment
pouvoir créer une nouvelle cohérence
dans un projet législatif non pas à
partir uniquement du projet de françois
fillon mais à partir de ce qui avait été
dit par les uns et par les autres
en partenariat avec nos amis de l'udf
avec lesquels nous avons beaucoup
travaillé c'est clairement un projet
pour faire réussir la france et c'est
clairement un projet qui s'inscrit dans
l'idée que notre pays pour réussir doit
évidemment atteindre le plein emploi
on garde donc cet objectif majeur qui
est celui de la compétitivité des
entreprises
on garde l'idée du cic e transformé en
baisse de charge
on ajoute une diminution de charges
patronales au delà et d'impôts de
production ont réduit modifie allège le
code du travail peut répondre aux
questions que vous souhaitez évidemment
tout ça et détaillés dans le document
voilà c'est un projet qui est clairement
tourné vers l'entreprise et sa capacité
à créer à la fois du pouvoir d'achat à
la fois la distribution des richesses
est évidemment de l'emploi en france on
n'oublie pas d'ailleurs que les
entreprises françaises sont assez en
retard dans le domaine de la
digitalisation et on a beaucoup de
propositions de cette nature mais la clé
des choses c'est aussi de se dire que
les français ne doivent pas être oubliés
de cela est que nous devons faire un
geste un effort important pour le
pouvoir d'achat des des français et cet
effort nous le faisons au travers d'un
certain nombre de mesures qui ne sont
pas que symbolique qui sont des mesures
importantes
la première c'est le fait que nous
n'augmenterons pas la tva françois
fillon avait proposé de le faire il
avait évolué sur le sujet mais nous
avons finalement décidé de ne pas le
faire nous n'augmenterons pas la tva
pourquoi parce que
il ya un discours un peu contradictoires
de considérer qu'il faut baisser les
prélèvements obligatoires et de l'autre
augmenter la tva qui touchait de près de
directement les les français donc nous
avons revu les choses là-dessus et la
base est tout à fait clair en face de
cela
emmanuel macron ils augmentent
massivement les impôts ils augmentent il
ya une augmentation cacher des impôts
chez emmanuel macron parce que personne
n'est vraiment insister sur le sujet
peut-être parce qu'il a pas eu débarque
au moment de l'élection présidentielle
est peut-être parce qu'il faut installer
ce débat maintenant celles assiégées
l'augmentation de la csg c'est plus de
20 milliards d'euros
ces 20 milliards d'euros frappe
directement les retraités les
fonctionnaires les professions libérales
et d'une certaine façon aussi même si
une baisse de cotisations sociales
salariales probablement un certain
nombre de salariés donc 20 milliards
d'euros au-delà de ces 20 milliards
d'euros il ya aussi ce que veut faire
emmanuel macron en ce qui concerne les
contrats d'assurance vie dont une
augmentation de l'impôt des contrats
d'assurance vie et puis en préparation
semble t'il une augmentation très forte
de l'imposition de l'immobilier pour
essayer de compenser ce que propose
emmanuel macron sur cette suppression en
partie partiel et peu efficace de la
taxe d'habitation
donc nous avons la volonté de baisser
les impôts impôt sur le revenu également
la peau sur le revenu baissera de 10 %
les heures sup sujet qui a été abordé
mille fois durant la campagne sujet
qu'on a abordé dans chaque entreprise
dans chaque usine qu'on pouvait visiter
c'est un consensus qui s'est dégagé
autour de l'idée que nous déchargeront
et défiscalisant les heures
supplémentaires
je vous ai je passerai peut-être sur les
points 2-2 détails
il ya évidemment l'idée de stabilité
fiscale qui est extrêmement importante
c'est la guerre qu'à partir du moment où
on fixe des règles du jeu il y aura 6 le
premier ministre le décide un collectif
budgétaire dès l'été et dès l'été nous
fixerons les règles
je sur le plan fiscal à partir de ce qui
a été dit et puis partir de ce que vous
lirez dans le document et nous
stabiliserons ses règles pour rendre la
france plus attractif au-delà de ces
sujets nous avons voulu aussi insistez
beaucoup sur les sujets régaliens qui
sont extrêmement lourds très préoccupant
pour les français on souhaite évidemment
aboutir une impunité zéro pour les
délinquants on renforce voir les polices
municipales on renforcera les places de
prison ray instaurera les pannes de
plancher les peines planchers
automatique on restera les peines
planchers automatique
on supprimera toutes les réductions
celle-ci automatique de deux peines
on inscrira la majorité pénale des
mineurs récidivistes
à 16 ans on continuera la guerre très
très très lourde contre le terrorisme en
liaison avec damman avec nos avec nos
alliés mais par exemple en ce qui
concerne les fichiers s ils seront
placés de manière préventive sous sûr
pour les plus dangereux à partir de cela
sous surveillance physique et
électronique renforcée on expulse sera
automatiquement les étrangers en
situation en situation de de relations
avec les mouvance salafiste
on augmentera la capacité et la qualité
du renseignement français enfin bref
beaucoup de sujets que vous découvrirez
également dans ceux dans ce texte
objectif important réduire de moitié le
l'immigration sur le quinquennat c'est
un point qui est fondamental
chaque année parlement votera des quotas
concernant l'immigration
on créera des zones de contrôles
renforcés dans les lieux de tensions sur
les questions d'immigration on pense
évidemment à calais il ya beaucoup
d'autres lieux on réformera les
procédures de droit d'asile
bref un sujet aussi traiter de façon
complète la défense
nous l'avions indiqué déjà mais nous
nous confirmons les forfaits en fins en
faveur de la dépend des france à hauteur
de 2% du produit intérieur brut et nous
nous en confortons aussi les deux
composantes que sont du nucléaire
français nous voulons une france plus
européenne et plus souveraine et c'est
un sujet qui me semble extrêmement
important la souveraineté du pays
elle peut s'exprimer de différentes
manières d'abord une souveraineté
financière
nous confirmons l'objectif de 100
milliards d'euros de baisses de la
dépense publique
cet effort est appuyée sur une baisse du
nombre de fonctionnaires que nous ne
chiffrent ont pas à 500 milles en fin de
quinquennat mais à 300 milles nous
conservons l'objectif de 500 milles mais
ne leur portons de deux ans nous voulons
un pacte de progrès avec la fonction
publique
on parlera avec la fonction publique de
la nécessaire augmentation du temps de
travail est bien une augmentation du
temps de travail dans le projet
politique
nous négocierons avec les fonctionnaires
ou des vidéos gossip ont aussi en
fonction de la qualité de vie et
des rémunérations de la nature des
rémunérations qui peuvent être portés il
peut pas y avoir de paupérisation des
fonctionnaires aujourd'hui l'idée que
l'on baisse automatiquement et tout le
temps le point d'indicé ou qu'on le gel
n'est évidemment pas une politique
d'avenir pour la fonction publique donc
faut remettre à plat les modes de
rémunérations de la fonction publique
nous avons beaucoup partagé avec lui des
i sur l'europe on veut une europe plus
forte
il n'y a pas de france forte sans europe
forte on essaye d indiquer en quoi cela
consiste
on intègre l'idée des contrats
commerciaux de la loyauté dans ces
contrats commerciaux dans ces traités
commerciaux on ajoute l'idée qu'on re
négociera la directive sur les
travailleurs détachés
lorsque quelqu'un travail en france le
salaire doit être français et les
charges doivent être également française
nous évoquons l'aide souveraineté
numérique c'est un sujet qui est souvent
sous les radars qui est un sujet
absolument essentiel pour l'avenir du
pays
enfin on indique que
nous signerons un contrat d'équité avec
tous les français pour essayer de
conserver notre modèle économique et
surtout notre propre modèle social je
pense particulièrement et au delà de la
sphère sociale nous voulons la retraite
à 65 ans progressivement nous voulons
que les français soient mieux remboursés
dans leur système de soins on explique
comment nous pensons qu'il ya des exclus
de la république dont on parle jamais ou
pas suffisamment que sont les handicapés
ou que ce sont encore les personnes en
situation de dépendance mais nous
concentrons les choses sur l'idée qu'il
peut pas y avoir deux poids deux mesures
en france particulièrement je pense à
l'équité territoriale
on a bien vu que les zones rurales voté
aujourd'hui largement au fond par des
espérances pour le front national
on doit essayer d'avoir un message clair
vis-à-vis des zones rurales et de la
ruralité française au delà même de
l'agriculture et nous appelons un
moratoire de la fermeture des services
publics en milieu rural
nous créons une agence d'égalité des
territoires et de redynamisation des
territoires et des zones rurales
nous parlons de l'accès au numérique
nous évoquons bref une ruralité ancré
dans la république c'est
particulièrement important
enfin la jeunesse souvent été oublié des
campagnes électorales
nous faisions un certain nombre de
propositions sur la genèse
spécifiquement nous proposons un contrat
avec la jeunesse de de france je pense
par exemple à l'idée de travailler mieux
avec les conseils régionaux état et
conseils régionaux pour faciliter la
mobilité professionnelle des jeunes que
ce soit une mobilité physique ou une
mobilité en termes d'emploi nous
évoquons l'accès au premier logement
qu'il soit locataire ou en forme de
propriété mais on a dit qu'un certain
nombre de mesures qui permettront je
l'espère 2 d'améliorer les conditions de
vie et d'entrer sur marché du travail
des jeunes de francs sans faille un
contrat sur la modernisation de la vie
publique la transparence de la vie
public évidemment nous baisserons le
nombre de parlementaires mais en même
temps pense qu'il faut plus de pouvoirs
et puis également les parlementaires
le parlement doit exercer totalement son
rôle il n'est pas question que le
parlement perde de sa puissance
vis-à-vis du gouvernement vis-à-vis du
président de la république on veillera à
tout cela et on explique comment
voilà un petit tour d'horizon d'un
projet cohérent globale qui évoquent
tous les points qui est un vrai projet
de gouvernement pour une nouvelle
majorité pour la france